so hi everyone my name is Dahlia Altman
I'm an algorithm researcher in via and I
want to talk to you today about offline
solutions to online problems and what do
I mean when I say offline solutions to
online problem so I'm gonna first talk
about what is the online problem so
let's imagine a really fun future where
we have VA service here in tel-aviv and
I want to get from my freshman apartment
to my via office so I open the app I
booked a ride and then quite quickly a
car will come and pick me up but then
what happens if a few minutes later
another person orders another ride which
is quite similar to mine and as we said
via is a ride-sharing service so this
for me as someone who looks at the data
quite often this looks like a ride that
could be shared but then maybe the other
person who booked this ride booked it
too far ahead in the future when the car
was maybe already here and if this was
the only car on the road this day in my
invented simulation then the other
person will not be able to use via to
get to work and they will be very sad
and now you laugh because it's Star Wars
and its towers theme but don't worry
no spoilers for the new movie so
everyone can relax so this was the
online part and a person wants to get
from point A to point B they book a ride
they get a ride they either get a ride
or don't get a ride and then they get
where they want to go but what if I had
a kind of Oracle that told me in advance
of all the rights that were going to
happen so let's say this Oracle told me
in advance that these two rides would
happen at 8:07
and a 12 then I would have been able to
calculate my route in advance and make
it so that everyone can ride together
and be happy and have less cars on the
road and everyone can get to work so
what is our motivation in this project
we have an online problem in via and in
other domains I guess as well where we
have individual actions
of people who want to make individual
actions and on the other side if we take
a step back and we look at the all of
the data that we have then we can like
get a broader perspective and we have
kind of when we look at the data points
one by one we can only see the data
point itself but when we look at the
data as a whole then we can see the
complexity and the patterns and make
smarter decisions like in this point
where I can group people together more
smartly more intelligently or something
so what is it good for looking at
everything at the same time so my goal
today is to convince you that it's good
and I'm gonna do that in three steps
first I'm going to kind of overview the
algorithm that we used for the offline
solution then I'm going to spend a
moment about Network X which is a Python
package that I used when I was working
on this project and I discovered some
fun stuff about that I would like to
share with you and then we're gonna do
some fun data exploration to see what
happened with the results of the project
so how did we do it well first we did a
literature survey there is a lot of
research going on around the world about
multi-agent traveling salesperson
problem and assignment and scheduling
and all kinds of fancy algorithms and so
this was a lot of inspiration for us to
see that there's a lot of a lot of
research going on and a lot of interest
in this kind of problems and just an off
topic note so probably you know this
that he do a literature survey and then
he started reading about crazy stuff so
I ended up reading about how worms were
they forage they make up a multi-agent
system I don't know I have no idea what
I read but now I can put a picture of
Jabba the Hutt and continue to the main
part so really how did we do it so I'm
building a graph where on the left side
I have the rights that I know I'll go
to happen and on the right side I have
the vans that are currently on the
system so we said that what we're doing
is we're trying to assign cars to people
so we can pick them up but remember via
is a ride-sharing service so I don't
want to connect edges between cars and
people I actually want to connect edges
between cars and kind of clusters of
people that can ride together because as
we saw before maybe two people can have
can share a ride but not everyone can so
I have these orange edges or multi edges
or clusters whatever of people that can
ride together and actually what I want
to do is connect edges between the cars
and the clusters of rides now this looks
a bit messy so let me kind of arrange it
a bit so I'm adding a middle layer the
middle layer contains all the rides that
can share so obviously each person can
ride by themselves and maybe one in two
can share a ride in one and three and
two and three and three and four but
maybe two and four cannot share a ride
so they want to be in my middle layer so
on the left side we have rides on the
middle size we have clusters of rides
and on the right side we have the vents
so I'm going to connect edges between
each ride and every cluster that
contains the ride I'm gonna do that for
all my rides and then I'm going to
connect vans with the clusters that they
can pick up now what I'm almost falling
now why isn't a van connected to all the
clusters where that can have that can
happen for many reasons such as location
and time and also about some features of
the system because let's say number four
is a rider that is riding in a
wheelchair and as we can see here the
first car is very non wheelchair
friendly so I cannot connect the edge so
I'm going to do that now for all the
cars and connect the edges between the
cars and the clusters that they can pick
up and the last step is remember I want
to pick up the people on the
left side of the graph and the middle
side is kind of my my helper layer that
helps me connect cars to ride so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm going to apply
an exact cover algorithm it's just a
fancy name for saying I basically just
want cars to pick up as many people as I
can so to sum up this part how did we
solve the offline algorithm we assume
that in advance we have all the requests
that of the rides that people that want
to use the service let's say today or
this morning or this hour so I'm taking
all the requests that they have and I
have all the events that are currently
in the system and I'm building a
three-sided graph sorry so I'm starting
by clustering the rides that can share
the ride and then I'm going to build the
suicided graph and then I find the exact
cover so I think I have some time to
insert questions during my talk so if
anyone wants to barge in yes so I just
insert like a constraint so I just have
a constraint on the graph that says this
car can pick up up to this many people
at the same time the question was how do
I address the problem of number of seats
in the writes yeah thank you yes yeah so
the question was how do I address the
fact that my motives as the via
developer algorithm research or whatever
and the rider are different because the
writer wants to get a sap from A to B
and I want to get everyone a SAP from A
to B so that's an interesting question
which there is no one answer for this is
a trade-off that we like daily have to
answer for and change the algorithm
constantly yeah you had a question
on the where nuclear maxilla
it's a it's kind of all inside it's it's
in the same component yeah the fact that
I have all the data in advance in the
online so what's the offline was the
question so in the online scenario I get
one request and now I need to find a car
to pick them up I get another request
two minutes later or three seconds later
and I have to answer for every reply at
this for every request at the time that
it was requested and here I assume that
I have not assumed but I use the fact
that I have all the requests and events
yeah let's just say that in short this
is a this is gonna be a long answer so
I'm not going to answer it completely
the end the question was how do i closer
the rise so this is a very difficult
task and unfortunate unfortunately I
don't have time enough to talk about it
today but it was for me one of the most
exciting parts of the algorithm I'm just
gonna say in short that we check and
then we see I'm sorry I don't have a
short answer for that more questions
yeah yeah so the question about was
about the time performance or the
complexity performance of the algorithm
because the middle layer of the clusters
has can potentially gropes financially
so this is one of the reasons that
clustering the rise was one of the most
exciting parts of the algorithm and well
that's a trade-off that we have to
consider when we work on this algorithm
[Music]
my short answer for this would be I just
try some sizes of datasets and see what
I can handle and work constantly on
improving the algorithm yeah so the
question was about if I understand
correctly so what I'm using here is past
data and so I'm not talking about future
data yet I'm gonna talk about it a
little bit more yes yeah so the comment
was that maybe the middle layer doesn't
grow exponentially because of the
constraints that I have of the system
this is quite correct this is most of
the time correct but then sometimes for
other constraints in the system it blows
up and then you run a simulation and you
come back in the morning and you look at
the same line that hasn't been completed
yet so I'm going to continue to my
network expert and yeah sorry so I'm
going to continue to my PI data part
this was he algorithm part sorry it took
so long so I'm going to talk about
Network X this is a Python part of my
talk and about the data exploration of
the results so Network X was a package
that I used to build this graph and to
do some stuff on it this is pretty much
the code I used you can take a picture
I'm gonna just kidding
let's look a bit closely so I import
networks Network X as an X just a
convention and what I'm going to show
you now is a function that I built that
takes as input we said the left side
which is the requests and the right side
which is the vans and then I built the
graph the three sided graph that we saw
so the first thing I want to comment
about Network X is that it allows use
for of lists and this is really
convenient as
Python user a really love list because
they allow me to use list comprehension
and that's a really fun feature for me
Python it just makes everything so much
more readable and easy to use and the
core code is pretty lean so I have lists
so I can use list comprehension so I can
take the requests and build the left
side of the graph and the fact that I
can use list comprehension allows me to
also use outside function to outsource
my I call it like the like the logical
part of my code so we talked about
getting the clusters which is a really
complicated problem and now I don't have
to include it in the core code of
building my graph I don't have to like
mess it up with all kind of yeah anyway
so it's really comfortable I really love
this feature and it lets me build a
graph really easily so just with one
line I can build the middle layer which
is like 50% of my algorithm and I can do
the same we said list comprehension so I
built a graph I built the edges as well
everything works with lists so it's very
easy and I build everything in the graph
and I think that's it and then when I
was building this this component in my
algorithm then I wanted to have I wanted
to see the graph you know like for
debugging or maybe showing the middle
output for some colleagues that I want
to talk to them about my algorithm and I
thought that I could just get like G dot
to draw and I would get like
automatically I would get this beautiful
graph and I even kind of expected
Network X to understand that this is a
three layered graph sadly I was wrong
and this is what I got which is totally
unhelpful and I started looking for for
solutions so there are many packages and
tools that allows me to take my network
x output and turn it into a beautiful
graph with all kinds of features and
interactive and blah blah blah
for me that was in
my goal I just wanted something that
could give me a beautiful graph in no
sweat and I didn't want to learn like
three four days now a new tool just for
my debugging purposes so I did some
digging and I found a feature called
position so the idea is again I'm using
like dick grumpy comprehension so I'm
using a dictionary to map my notes to
points in the plane and then I can tell
the position argument that this is a
three-sided graph now I only have to
position the nodes and everything else
happens automatically and so I position
all my notes for three layers and now
everything is ok and order is restored
to the galaxy
so in short Network X I hope I showed
you some new features about using lists
which allows us to use list
comprehension which allows us to
outsource the logical part of our code
to make the core code of building the
graph more lean and comfortable and easy
to read and use position for easy
drawing because we don't work on
learning new tools when we don't have to
even though it's really fun but
sometimes there's just there's just no
time so after the third and last part of
my talk the data exploration so I want
to share with you some results that we
had of this project and I want to share
with you some fun stuff that we learned
from it so data exploration for many
people means different things so for me
when I talk today on this stage on this
project when I say data exploration
I just mean translating data into into
information I was told I should replace
it to wisdom or knowledge but it doesn't
rhyme so you get my context right so
translating data to information I'm
taking the output of my algorithm and
I'm trying to understand what do I see
here like this is just data points what
do I see inside so my first example I'm
taking here actual requests that
happened that people asked for a ride
and I download the request and use them
I call it a scenario so in this scenario
I have actual requests by actual people
that want to book a ride in a city and I
use two different algorithms one
algorithm which I call the online
algorithm is a simulation that really
simulates the online algorithm that we
have in via and I just run it offline
but it simulates the online property of
reading each request when it's I don't
know when it's in the system and I have
the offline algorithm which is what I
showed you today that takes all the
requests at the same time and sees how
how they can match the cars to the
people better so what do we see here I
had three scenarios one where I had
three vans in the system 507 vans so we
see I'm undersupplied I can't always
pick up all the people that I want to
pick up and gladly I didn't do something
really wrong so the offline algorithm is
smarter than the online algorithm which
is kind of it's relaxing to see that it
has some value but now what can I see
from here so I see that there are even
when I have seven vans which I'm still
under supplied so what do I do in a
situation in real time like in via that
we have actual
met the unmet demand when there are
actually people who booked a ride and I
can't find a van to come and pick them
up so what do I do
so what is the information that I can
extract from this chart so we said that
let's okay let's think about it like
this so I have the PI of all the people
that book to ride in this scenario it
was I think it was like a more
in one of the cities in New York and not
one of the cities in New York one of the
cities that we are operating New York
has more see New York City's Tel Aviv so
there are there is a portion of the pie
of people that we were not able in the
simulation we were not able to book them
a ride so what can I learn from this so
I think about it in the following sense
I think that if I could convince a
portion of my users to pre book the
rides then maybe I could take take this
portion of people that pre-booked the
ride which means that I know in advance
of the time and location of the request
and for this portion of for this portion
of the pie of the people that pre-booked
the ride I can use the offline algorithm
and increase the entire percent piece of
the pie of people that I can serve and
this is kind of a business Intel kind of
idle out of the box and this is actually
a trend that's going on right now in the
transportation business i I don't know
if you use taxis I use Texas quite often
and for some for some apps if I want to
pre booked my ride then I have to pay an
extra fee and what we see here is that
maybe I should encourage my users the
other way around maybe I should
encourage them to pre book the ride and
not find them for that so that's like
one happy thing that we have from this
from this simulation next one so what we
see here is a graph of the time of day
so this is the morning we said and these
are waiting time in minutes so all of
the of all of the requests that happen
between 7 & 8 o'clock this is the
average time they waited for the car and
so this is pretty much I would say the
rush hour
look at this graph and I see on the left
side like just before the rush hour the
blue line which represents the offline
algorithm
it gives it only picks up requests that
have a short waiting time so I look at
this and I think wait this isn't
happening like during the rush hour it's
not like it's just better it actually
does something different so I look at
these results and I think maybe like a
kind of an actionable insight that if
just before rush hour I have a request
that takes me away from the center of
action or from where the rush hour is
going to be maybe I can just insert like
a toggle in the algorithm and say just
don't go far away from the center of
action just before rush hour and the
third certain last insight that I have
so this is the the same graph this is
rush hour and this is the detour so why
do I keep mind of detour we said VI is a
ride-sharing app so maybe some the car
comes and picks me up but then I don't
go directly to my destination I do a
small detour because I want to pick up
other people or maybe someone else did I
pick up a detour detour so they can pick
me up or something like that
and I look at this graph and I see okay
so there's a kind of I would say a
correlation let's not say causation but
there's a correlation between between
shorter detours and the offline
algorithm that manages to pick up more
people now I look at this and I honestly
don't really know what to tell you
because if we tell the like the online
algorithm just don't make large detours
then it picks up less people because
it's not able to do the detour to pick
up more people and it's kind of
confusing and it's not like I can look
at it and okay this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna fix my algorithm what I see in
this chart is that this gives me another
place to explore like I look at this and
I say okay this is this is my next
research I'm gonna see what's going on
here and this is a really fun part for
me likes give you the what is my next
move like okay
got that I got that what is the offline
algorithm gives me that it's not like
straight off out of the box what is the
next research that I can do so to sum up
the data exploration part which I hope
that I convinced you that doing of off
line algorithms is interesting and
informative so first we saw that we can
get business Intel out of the box we saw
also that we have action will be
actionable insights that we can insert
to our algorithm algorithm and we also
saw that there are always places to
drill further down and to continue the
research so this brings me to my
take-home message which is that well
doing this project it's it takes a lot
of resources and it takes patience and
it also takes creativity and for me it
was really fun but mostly takes
resources so I really hope that I
convinced you today that putting the
effort for those resources could have a
lot of insights and gain and that I hope
we all have the resources and the energy
and the excitement to take a step back
and look at the online problems that
we're dealing with daily and look at the
big picture and see what insights we can
gain from T from looking at the big
picture so I wish you all a wonderful
exploration and thank you for listening
[Music]
anyone has any further questions I think
it kind of like just remanence yeah the
question was how do I get the data so
it's I can just download the data that
if we had let's say we add via today in
Tel Aviv so I could go home right now
not right now but maybe tomorrow morning
and download all the requests that
happened today in Tel Aviv and then
apply the algorithm and know for today
that's the idea that I take request that
already happened and then I apply the
algorithm for request has already
happened and see what happened what is
the difference between the performance
of the simulation of the offline
algorithm and the simulation of the
online algorithm so the question was can
the algorithm changed its mind and the
idea here here is that I have all the
data in advance so I don't have to
change my mind I the online algorithm I
don't know I'm not sure how I suppose
the online algorithm can change its mind
like but imagine I pick you up and then
afterwards
yeah if people are joining a different
so I'm gonna answer during the break the
short answer would be that if I already
picked you up then I can't really change
my mind and let's talk about it on the
rake so thank you everyone
[Applause]